hello everybody i'm back again having a
little sigma mail 7 a.m recording
session
um today's video is going to be on
vaultdb
um i should probably just mention that
there's like a small chance i'm not able
to post tomorrow just because we're
having like an entire school-wide party
and i'm going to be very inebriated the
whole day
that being said i'm going to do my best
to try and find a little bit of extra
time today to crank out one more video
over the course of the day so that i can
have it ready to be posted for tomorrow
at five like normal
that being said let's talk about volt db
which is another cool concept
okay so volt db what is it basically um
it's just a really quick background it's
yet another new sql database that i've
actually mentioned a little bit in the
past when talking about serializability
and the reason that this one is kind of
worth mentioning is because it takes a
very interesting approach to
serializability and that's how it's able
to kind of optimize its performance over
a traditional sql database
so what is the design philosophy of
volte being well recall that traditional
sql databases tend to use two-phase
locking so that means there's a bunch of
shared and exclusive blocks on each row
that are being you know both read and
written by transactions and as a result
that means transactions often have to
wait for one another there's a ton of
overhead to actually grabbing and
releasing locks and in addition to that
there's frequent deadlocks where two
processes are waiting on the same
resource and as a result neither of them
can actually go ahead and proceed
instead what volt db has actually done
to simplify this entire process is
actually just have each database running
in a single threaded manner as you can
see below it's basically just a queue of
transactions which can be both reads and
writes and the cpu on a given database
node is just going to execute them in
some serial order
and obviously what that does is it
avoids the need to lock because you just
have one process operating on things
so uh you know just executing in a
single threaded manner isn't going to be
enough um because
you know just the fact that if you just
took a single or a normal mysql database
and we're just like okay we're only
going to use one thread
then it's going to just be super slow so
volt db obviously has to make other
modifications to go ahead and actually
support this design decision so there
are two major things that they do
in order to kind of make this all work
and the first is that all data is going
to be stored in memory and the second or
that transactions must first be stored
as stored procedures so i'm going to go
ahead and go through those both in more
detail right now
so as far as storing data and memory
goes why would we want to do this well
for starters it means there's no disk
stalls there's a ton of disk io in
databases that we have to wait on and
just by putting everything in memory we
can actually go ahead and just mitigate
this problem obviously ram is more
expensive and there's less of it to be
had but the founders of volte b believe
that in the modern day you know when you
can have literally hundreds of gigabytes
of memory on a single machine it should
be sufficient to actually store your
database on there and you know if you're
out of space you can probably end up
sharding that anyways
additionally in order to ensure the
durability of writes
voltdb has something known as the
command log where the command log is a
little bit different than a write ahead
log however it basically just says
instead of storing the results of every
transaction it just stores the
transaction instructions itself because
it kind of reduces the overhead of
writing to disk
those disk writes can either be done
synchronously or asynchronously if
they're done synchronously you can be
sure that all of your writes are durable
because it means that everything is
going to the disk before it's going into
memory if it's done asynchronously those
two are happening at the same time and
then in theory some writes can be lost
but between that command log
in conjunction with consistent
snapshotting
you can be pretty certain that you're
going ahead and getting durable rights
um obviously again using memory is going
to work much better with a single
threaded database because you don't have
to avoid or you don't have to go ahead
and basically switch a bunch of disk
pages into the memory cache all the time
in order to modify them and then right
back to disk so avoiding all this disk
io and all this overhead involved is
really huge for being able to run on a
single thread
okay nextly we have stored procedures so
um just to kind of remind everyone what
a stored procedure is a stored procedure
is basically saying that for every
single transaction for every kind of
block of code
as opposed to going ahead and sending
the database instructions uh one at a
time over the network you basically send
it a block of
database instructions that you know can
take in something like a function
argument because i believe voltdb's
stored procedures written in java so the
point is you're basically going ahead
and sending it a java function with some
sort of callback that's actually going
to be able to do
read modify update transactions by using
the result of that read and so this way
what this means is that instead of
having to read the database
having all that data come back over the
network
while the database is basically just
waiting for the user to respond with
something else and then tell the
database what to do
the database from the get-go is familiar
with what it needs to do regardless of
what that first read value comes up with
so as a result stored procedure
stops something known as user stalls
which is basically waiting for the
network on these kind of
you know multi-statement transactions
where there's some logic as for what to
do after a given read
um so that way basically between the
memory and the stored procedures we can
basically ensure that all of the time
spent in our you know our database or
any time that it takes for an operation
to happen is simply just because of the
cpu cycles being devoted to it as
opposed to something like disk io or
network io
okay so let's quickly touch upon the
partitioning and replication of voltdb
basically since data is only stored in
memory we know that we can't store that
much of it on a given node and so it's
pretty inevitable that it's going to be
sharded
and you would share that like a pretty
traditional
mysql database or any other relational
database where it's probably just going
to be done on
the primary key of a row
so any transaction that is going to be
reaching multiple shards basically the
first thing that happens is the
transaction is going to reach one shard
and then that shard acts as a
coordinator node so for reads it's going
to kind of go ahead and parallelize
those read requests and then combine
them together and for writes it's
probably going to have to use something
like two-phase commit or some other
atomic commit protocol
the volt db creators do basically say
that in an ideal world the majority of
the transactions are going to happen on
one partition which is pretty much the
case for all databases you want to
minimize the network latency involved
and in order to do that what they allow
you to do which is kind of interesting
is for certain tables you know say you
have a really small table but you know
that you're constantly going to be
joining on that table for most of these
partitions you can actually just go
ahead and replicate the entirety of that
small table to every single node so that
way you could reduce the network latency
when making those joints
it's almost kind of reminiscent of
like broadcast hash joins
in streaming i believe where you just
take an entire copy of a table and load
it into memory for really quick joins
then finally we should note that
replication can be done both in terms of
just like a traditional single leader
sense where you can
have kind of those read-only replicas
but also they allow you to do cross-data
center replication using a multi-leader
configuration and what that means is
that you're going to be introduced to
write conflicts and in the event that
those happen basically volte b says
if we have two operations that are
blatantly conflicting and one of them is
either an insert or an update and the
other is a delete the delete always has
precedence
and in the event that neither of them is
a delete
basically use the last right wins
operation by choosing the one with the
later time stamp
okay so in conclusion
we can see that volte b is yet another
new sql database that chooses to
optimize on the existing sql design by
targeting two-phase locking we saw this
with spanner as well because
spanner is kind of designed for those
huge read-only queries where having to
hold locks on all the rows that you're
reading in order to get snapshot
consistency is extremely inefficient so
vault db actually goes ahead and
performs this by literally just running
through all operations on each node one
at a time it's pretty curious it's
rather interesting how they do this kind
of just by
keeping everything in memory and then
using those stored procedures so it's
definitely a little bit of an unfamiliar
design however it is extremely fast in
the sense that um
they were able to get this working
really well and so i think it's worth
talking about and it is a good case
study on actual serial execution and
kind of what you need to do in order to
support that type of workload